[Music]
this engagement is one of the most
rebellious things a royal has ever done
Megan Marco is American she's divorced
and she's black this is not the
traditional recipe for princess
if you thought Prince Harry broke the
Royal mold when he married mm just
imagine how they'll rewrite the regal
rule of parenting here's a look at how
babies Sussex will make history this
baby has been shaking up the British
royal family since the big news was
announced in October I can Markel's
friends through her a baby shower in New
York a couple months before her due date
it started with Megan's epic baby shower
the internet party included some
big-name guests including Amal Clooney
Serena Williams the soiree was held at
New York's Marc hotels where gifts were
placed in a decorated crib and guests
dined on cuisine from a Michelin star
chef they brought in somebody to explain
how to arrange flowers as for the price
tag on Megan's pre-baby shindig a
reported quarter of a million dollars
and the entire event was as unbraid
--is-- as it gets
Kate Middleton didn't have one shower
for any of her babies because the world
experts would say it's seen as tacky
because it shows that like they need the
presents when they don't
Megan's fourth great-grandfather was
actually property of this plantation
owner Megan is proud of her heritage and
is spoken about growing up with a white
father and african-american mother
because I'm biracial I was able to get
into so many more rooms because they
didn't exactly know where they could put
me now her baby will become the first
modern biracial baby who's in line for
the British throne
[Music]
you know I'm born and raised in LA it's
very exciting that you know there's
gonna be a mixed-race baby in the royal
family
that's half America before her wedding
to Prince Harry the palace confirmed
that Megan will eventually become an
official Brit but it's still unclear
whether she'll renounce her American
ties or just become a dual citizen name
one thing you couldn't live without my
passport
either way baby Sussex will be the first
British royal to meet the criteria for
US citizenship this baby is seventh in
line to the throne and is unlikely to be
an HRH unless Queen Elizabeth steps in
like she did for William and Kate's
three kids Gary and Megan's firstborn
won't be a prince or princess what's
more the Sussex duo could actually
decide to forego a royal title
altogether just like Princess Anne did
for Harry's cousins Peter and Zara
[Music]
Britain the royal family is a white and
each establishment and I think really
it's time to change another way Megan
and Harry are bringing about change
their decision to raise baby Sussex at
Windsor's Frogmore cottage rather than
Kensington Palace Harry's very keen for
baby sticks to be brought up in the
countryside but he's also keen to strike
out on his own now we're also hearing
rumblings the Sussex fam might
temporarily relocate to Africa a
continent they hold near and dear but no
matter where babies Sussex grows up
Megan Harry's child is already
monumental that's my baby so I'm very
proud